our morning must-read is about something
crowding out a discussion of the
American labor economy that's Puerto
Rico Matt Levine the giant over at
Bloomberg view writing up a piercing
note were to Rico
obviously has borrowed too much money
which necessarily means that people have
been lending it too much money back in
February Christy Culpepper ace Kentucky
fiscal expert wrote that hedge funds
will continue to stuff Puerto Rico like
a giant debt pinata until a shift in
capital flows busting open car wreck
Adana with us with Bloomberg economics
and lots were not just on with ECRI Carl
to you first I think this is an
important point there's got to be
somebody on the other side of the trend
is action somebody's got to be dumb
enough to buy Greek debt and take it on
board somebody's got to be dumb enough
to buy Puerto Rico debt and take it on
board absolutely and if you look at the
economic fundamentals in either case
whether it's Greece or Puerto Rico the
economies are mired in recession the
Puerto Rican economy has been struggling
terribly they can't pay their bills if
they're not growing lots when the yield
logs are at a free lunch yields don't go
higher
that's when prices go down so they can
sort of be confident right now is that
part of the reason Porto Rico got into
trouble well I mean as you were saying
there's two sides to the trade there's
also the lenders and here I think with
there's a lot of strange things that
have happened with easy money in high
liquidity and search for yield and we
may be seeing aspects of that popping up
here and as you say when you're in a
recession it's very tough to service
your debt luckily you know a lot of the
world isn't in recession so that's
helping things off because I'm being and
I think keeping us away from that